I built my name's Elijah bender I'm a
PhD candidate in history at the
University of California Santa Barbara
and I'm a huge car enthusiast you can
see I have my Mustang shirt on here do
you think in the future building classic
cars and performance engines will be
something that we just have to give up
or is there hope for deer heads like me
who also want to be environmentally
responsible are things like ethanol and
other biofuels viable options thank you
here's what I think is gonna happen
my gearhead friend once you have access
to a high-performance electric vehicle
you will never go back to gas powered
vehicles ethanol Sh methanol electric
cars are just much more fun they have so
much more torque than gas-powered cars
they have maximum torque at zero and I
can tell you I'm a guy of a certain age
and my cousin had a Mustang he had a 65
Mustang the 289 cubic inch engine it's
very reliable engine it's okay it's an
old car it doesn't steer it doesn't stop
the seats are hard it's a rough ride
after you have an electric car you just
won't want to anything to do with those
you'll see now you're getting your
degree in history but it doesn't take
that much if you're into cars and the
mechanisms that run the valve lifters
yeah those cars had push rods I mean
just they didn't have overhead cams
those old cars what are you talking
about if you can understand the
mechanisms in a traditional gas-powered
engine from the muscle-car era let's say
you will have no trouble understanding
the electric vehicles the electric
motors in the same way you have to be
respectful of the energy and a gas tank
you will be respectful of the
electricity in a big battery and you
will figure it out man
I'm telling you so what did I do a
couple weeks ago I watched the new James
Bond movie Spectre he's James Bond he
has a British sports car 0 to 60 in 3.1
seconds this is in a British movie and
so they still use the English system
I was in a Tesla about two months ago
zero to sixty in 2.8 seconds and I'm
telling you 0.3 seconds is a lot I mean
you have no trouble telling who won if
you're behind by 0.3 seconds several car
lengths you'll never go back man embrace
the future
let's have better steering mechanisms
let's have self-driving cars let's have
a better system for operating the
accelerator you know you on a motorcycle
you do this and you have much better
fine confined motor skills here than you
do here so that's that's just left over
from when we ran out of hands and the
cars were first design so I can imagine
a car with a joystick and the throttle
that you're operated with your hands and
you could be part of that man let's go
it's changed the world we want to
electrify all ground transportation cars
and trains then we want to use your
ethanol or something like at biofuels to
power planes and we may use hydrogen to
power planes but all that aside I
strongly encourage you to move away from
your love of gas burning vehicles there
they make fossil they make carbon
dioxide using fossil fuels and they're
just lower performance than what's
available even now the test was the
first thing I drove a Nissan Leaf for
three years I drove the Mini Cooper
electric experimental I drove the the i3
the BMW i3 you'll never go back man
telling you
you